una de las cosas que puso contenta
francia tras la victoria de joe biden
fue la promesa del candidato demócrata
de reintegrar a su país en el acuerdo
del clima de parís del año 2015 del que
se salió efectivamente en noviembre del
año pasado primero porque eeuu es el
segundo emisor de gases de efecto
invernadero del planeta es responsable
de un 15 por ciento de las emisiones y
con el acuerdo del clima de parís se
comprometía a reducir estas emisiones en
un 25 por ciento de aquí al año 2025 y
con respecto al año 2005 pero en segundo
lugar también porque eeuu es un
contribuyente económico muy importante
primero de la convención de naciones
unidas por el clima la que organiza las
cop y en segundo lugar del fondo verde
que es el que ayuda a los países en
desarrollo primero a disminuir sus
emisiones y en segundo lugar a adaptarse
al cambio climático pero reintegrando el
acuerdo del clima de parís de la huella
de carbono de estados unido por decirlo
alguna manera no se reduce demasiado por
lo mismo los asesores medioambientales
del presidente electo le han dicho que a
través de decreto el debería revertir
159 medidas que tomó en contra del medio
ambiente
donald trump también a través de decreto
entre ellas por ejemplo
ser el comité consultivo de la ciencia
del clima que debe preparar justamente
eeuu para el cambio climático el sabin
center de la universidad de columbia ha
aconsejado el presidente piden que
restablezca la protección de los océanos
los lagos y de las costas
justamente esa protección había sido
eliminada en el año 2017 y llevó por
ejemplo interrumpir un programa de
limpieza de los grandes lagos que son
los que dan agua a 40 millones de
estadounidenses y canadienses y en
tercer lugar sus asesores le aconsejan
que niegue el permiso al proyecto de
oleoducto keystone xl que haya sido
autorizado por el presidente donald
trump y al que se oponen las comunidades
autóctonas por las por los graves daños
ecológicos que puede causar y que por
cierto había sido interrumpido es ese
permiso en noviembre del año pasado por
un juez de eeuu